[Applause]
four assists
Lopez
going at it
coaches getting involved and it spills
into the sports table
and Lopez he has been upset the entire
second half
and look at Lopez a man possessed
let's take a look here Lyle's committed
to foul and then he just mushed Lopez
into face but Lopez has been chirping
this is yeah that doesn't show the whole
lead up to the whole altercation
I'm gonna say this I do not condone
fighting yeah but the team that I have
been covering over the last several
years hasn't had that type of fight in
them and if you want to get to the
postseason if you want to have success
you need to have a little bit of a dog
in you and Trey